لكن لكره القدم ايضا الجوانب وايجابيه على
الشعوب في بعض الاحيان ودعونا نعود بالزمن
لاكثر من 30 عاما
اتساءل احيانا عن مكان ليحدث في غزلافيا
لو كنا وصلنا لنهائي كاس العالم تساؤل ضل
يراود فريق
هزيدش لاعب منتخب ايروسلافيا الذي اضاع
ركله الجزاء الحاسمه في ربع نهائي كاس
العالم في 1990 ومعه الاف من ابناء الشعبي
غزلافيا كانت يوغسلافيا على شفلل انهيار
وكان الجميع يعلم ان ذلك سيحدث ابي سبب
تصاعدي القوميه بين الشعوب وبدات احتكاكات
بين القاده السياسيين لكن اداء المنتخب
حسن المزاج الشعبي واعاد مشهد رفع الاعلام
اعلام غزلافيا في كل من سرابيو وبالجراد
وزغلل لكن الكره وجه اخر
نفس الوقت يغزلافيا كما منعت هذا لانهيار
في وقت ما اجت حربا اهليه وساعدت عليها في
وقت اخر عام 1990 معركه في مباراه ما بين
دينا مزغرف الكرواتيه وريد ستار بلغراد
الصبي ابهرت اولا علاماتنا اول علامات
تصدع يوغسلافيا وقتها حدثت اشتباكات وكانت
ركله اللاعب الكرواتي بوبانا لاحد
الشرطيين الرساله واضحه الكروات والصرب لا
يمكنهما التعايش بعد الان
تشققات تعمقات بعد سته اشهر مباراه اخرى
بين باتيزان بلغراد الصربي
اقتحملالها انصار الاخير الملعب واحرق ولم
يغزلافيا رساله جديده فقط الدوله سلطتها
على الجزء الكروتين من البلاد
اشتعلت الحرب في مارس 1991 حينها اعطت
كرواتيا اكثر لاعبيها من حمل السلاح رات
انهم اكثر قدره على خدمه الامه باقدامهم
مع كما تفعل اوكرانيا اليوم عدد منهم
كانوا في منتخبه يوغسلافيا 1990 ومضوا
ليقدموا البلد الوليد الى العالم كرواتيا
في 1998